[Musique]
je voulais juste me présenter je
m'appelle will newman vous ne devez pas
vous approcher à moins de deux mètres
vous connaissez les règles laisse moi
deviner quel genre de gars qui ignorent
les règles parce que tu as l'impression
que c'est toi qui commande j'ai pas
raison pas tout à fait tort je trouve ça
sexy et toi tu trouve ça sexy de même
beau d'aller tout le monde mais pour mon
fonctionna à 300% pour l'instant les
gens qui ont la mucoviscidose ne doivent
pas s'approcher à moins de deux mètres
les uns des autres partis sinon on
pourrait se refiler nos bactéries
y'a rien qui va nous sauver la vie on
respire de l'air en bouteille non je
refuse de croire que je peux voir
d'accueil des soins c'est quoi ça on va
suivre nos traitements semble comme ça
je serai sûr que tu fais tout ce qui
permet aux toujours à chercher le moyen
de passer plus de temps avec moi
installa me dis pas que pour une fois
que tu t'intéresses un mec il faut
qu'ils aient aussi la mucoviscidose
j'aime bien de voir comme ça comment
positif pour moi j'ai rien à porter de
jolies offert
c'est sûr qu'on prévoit toujours une
grande histoire d'amour à l'hôpital ah
au fait vous ratez magnifique et
courageuse
je voudrais pouvoir de toucher
t'approche pas de lui je reste tout le
temps à deux mètres je sais tu contracte
ce qu'il a et tu peux dire adieu à la
transplantation
on n'est pas comme les autres
peut pas prendre ce genre de risque
[Musique]
tout ce temps j'ai vécu pour mes
traitements au lieu de suivre mes
traitements pour vivre et je m'en vais
on a vu
[Musique]
tout ce que je veux c'est être veto
après tout ce que la mucoviscidose en a
pris
dérange pas de grappiller quelque chose
demi tour
[Musique]
c'est comme cm
on se rapproche des 50 hâtives
offert